This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Maybe the last time I went out there was 2005 as early stages dating this lady. I went over to her house. She was like, I just had this crazy dream where you and I were like walking through a field and and came on a spaceship And I was like, oh yeah, you want to go there? And she's like, what are you talking about? It's like, no, that's a place. We can we can go. It's not far And we finally saw this place. She was just like overtaken with how magical it was to see this thing that just doesn't seem real
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。也许我最后一次去那里是在2005年，当时正处于和一位女士的初约阶段。我去了她家。她说，我刚刚做了一个疯狂的梦，梦见你和我一起走过一片田野，然后遇到了一艘宇宙飞船。我说，哦，真的吗，你想去那儿看看吗？她说，你在说什么？我说，不，那是个地方，我们可以去，离这儿不远。我们终于看到了这个地方，她被看到这个看似不真实的东西时所感到的神奇深深震撼了
with how magical it was to see this thing that just doesn't seem real. Why are you guys taking us out to the middle of nowhere? Hey, hey, hey, you don't know where we're gonna go. It's a secret. I was really lucky to grow up in Ann Arbor. We had great record stores and an art house movie theater, and of course Ann Arbor is the home of the University of Michigan, so there was a lot going on for Small Town. But it was a small town, and I was a misfit. And like a lot of young misfits and small towns, I was bored and disaffected and angry a lot. That misfit is Alex Goldman.
被看到这个看似不真实的东西时所感到的神奇深深震撼了。你们为什么要把我们带到这荒郊野岭？嘿，嘿，嘿，你们不知道我们要去哪儿。这是个秘密。我很幸运能在安娜堡长大。我们有很好的唱片店和艺术影院，当然安娜堡也是密歇根大学的所在地，所以对于一个小镇来说，这里有很多丰富的内容。但它终究是个小镇，而我曾是个格格不入的人。就像许多小镇上的年轻异类一样，我常常感到无聊、不满和愤怒。那个格格不入的人就是亚历克斯·戈德曼。
He's a producer at the radio show on the media and he now lives in New York City. I hated high school, I was a bad student, and most of my friends went to different schools. In fact, although I've gone by Alex my entire life, that's actually my middle name. My first name's Michael, and for at least half of my high school career, my teachers and peers all called me Michael. It was like I walked around pretending to be a completely different person for most of my waking life. I felt like I didn't belong anywhere, and I desperately wanted to escape this oppressively
他是广播节目《媒体上的媒体》的制作人，现在住在纽约市。我讨厌高中，我曾是个差生，而且我大部分的朋友都去了不同的学校。事实上，虽然我一辈子都叫亚历克斯，但那其实是我的中间名。我的本名叫迈克尔，在我高中生涯的至少一半时间里，我的老师和同龄人都叫我迈克尔。这就好像我在清醒的大部分时间里都假装成一个完全不同的人。我觉得自己不属于任何地方，我迫切地想要逃离这个令人窒息的
small town that felt completely devoid of wonder. And then I found Hey Yoon. Alright. Okay, where are we? I hope someone brought a flashlight. No, no, no, we can't be using flashlights. See us. Oh, just the fluggy man.
完全感觉不到奇迹的小镇。然后我发现了海尤恩。好吧。好了，我们这是在哪儿？我希望有人带了手电筒。不，不，不，我们不能用手电筒。会被看到的。哦，只是个小飞虫罢了。
Take my lighter. The only way you found out about Hey Yoon was if someone took you there. It was like there was the secret club of kids who knew about it. I got initiated when I was 15. You drive out into the middle of nowhere, deep in the country, and park alongside this dirt road. All right, so step one, we've gotta get over that fence. There was this fence that you had to climb over. It had the sign on it.
拿我的打火机。你发现海尤恩的唯一方法就是有人带你去。就好像有一个知道这个秘密的儿童俱乐部。我15岁时加入了。你开车开到荒郊野岭的深处，把车停在一条泥土路旁。好了，第一步，我们得翻过那个栅栏。这里有一个你必须爬过去的栅栏。上面有块牌子。
Guys, I don't know about this. Come on, man. The sign read, turn back. Turn back. This is private property. You're not welcome here for any reason. Please, now. Turn back and leave in peace.
伙计们，我不知道这样行不行。得了吧，伙计。牌子上写着，回去。回去。这是私人财产。这里不欢迎你，无论出于什么原因。求求你，现在。回去，安详地离开。
Turn back and leave in peace. It almost felt like a dare. Trust me, this is going to change your life! Once you were over the fence, you passed alongside a white farmhouse. The guy that owns that house is crazy. I heard a rumor that he shot a kid full of rocks off of getting near his house. I heard he's got a pack of attack dogs.
回去，安详地离开。这感觉几乎像是一种挑衅。相信我，这会改变你的一生！翻过栅栏后，你会路过一栋白色的农舍。拥有那栋房子的人是个疯子。我听说有个传言说，他因为有人靠近他的房子，开枪把一个小孩打满了石子。我听说他养了一群攻击犬。
I heard he's skinned pack of attack dogs. I heard he's skin to kid alive. A path behind the house led to this thin line of trees but once you made it through the trees you're in this huge field and there was something else there in the field. Something man-made. Something really big. right up here right up here okay here's what we got to do when we get up to that clearing everybody run as fast as you can how far until you see it okay ready three two one go Three, two, one. Go! There it is.
我听说他剥了一群攻击犬的皮。我听说他把一个小孩活着剥皮了。房子后面有一条小路通向这排稀疏的树林，但一旦穿过树林，你就会来到一个巨大的田野里，田野里还有别的东西。某种人造的东西。某种非常大的东西。就在这儿，就在这儿，好吧，我们要做的就是，当我们走到那片开阔地时，大家以最快的速度奔跑，还要跑多远才能看到它？好吧，准备好，三、二、一，走。三，二，一。走！在那里。
Whoa. Welcome to Hey-Hoon. Oh, it's beautiful. The structure was made mostly of wood, with a canopy of teflon and nylon stretched over a metal frame. From the base, there were stairs leading up to a platform about 10 feet off the ground, suspended over a boulder about the size of a Volkswagen bug.
哇。欢迎来到海尤恩。哦，太美了。这个结构主要由木头制成，上面覆盖着一层特氟龙和尼龙织物，拉伸在金属框架上。从底部有楼梯通往一个高出地面约10英尺的平台，平台悬浮在一块大约大众甲壳虫汽车大小的巨石上方。
At the top of the stairs, there were these two pieces of glass in the floor, and one night a friend stood underneath with a lighter while I looked down from on top. There was an etching on one of those pieces of glass. It said, the Hayun Pavilion. H-E-Y-O-O-N Hayun, the Hayun Pavilion. There was other signage too. One sign that sort of welcomes you there.
在楼梯的顶部，地板上有两块玻璃，有一天晚上，一个朋友站在下面拿着打火机，而我从上面往下看。其中一块玻璃上有一处蚀刻。上面写着，海尤恩亭。H-E-Y-O-O-N海尤恩，海尤恩亭。还有其他标牌。有一个牌子算是欢迎你来到这里。
This pavilion is a work of art. Designed and carefully put together for more than two years by many workmen and artisans. If you by some happenstance are now here in this place, please take pleasure in its serenity. But please do not disturb it nor to face its beauty in any way. Its beauty alone is your reward for meandering here. For your respect, the spirit of the designer artist will leave you in peace. But then right next to that, there is this other sign. It said, and I'm quoting, if you are here, you shouldn't be.
这座亭子是一件艺术品。由众多工匠和艺术家精心设计和组装了两年多。如果你碰巧来到了这个地方，请享受这里的宁静。但请不要打扰它，也不要以任何方式损坏它的美。它本身的美就是你漫步于此的奖励。为了你的尊重，设计艺术家的灵魂会让你平静地离开。但就在旁边，还有另一块牌子。上面写着，我引用一下，如果你在这里，你就不应该在这里。
This is a privately owned farm off limits to outsiders. You have crossed clearly marked keep out and no trespassing signs on fence lines and gates. Please, now, respect the owner's privacy by leaving this place in peace. Thank you. Some of the no trespassing signs may have backfired a little bit, because there was this, I feel like there's this sort of contrariness to teenagers where it's like, well, if there's that many no trespassing signs, then it must be awesome.
这是一个私人拥有的农场，禁止外人进入。你已经穿过了栅栏和大门上清晰标有“请勿进入”和“严禁 trespassing”的标志。现在，请通过安详地离开这个地方来尊重房主的隐私。谢谢。有些“严禁进入”的标志可能适得其反，因为我觉得青少年身上有一种逆反心理，就好像是，好吧，如果有那么多“严禁进入”的标志，那它一定棒极了。
I rounded up a few of my high school friends and talked to them about, hey, you. It seems like it still isn't drenched in their minds as it has been in mine. It was, I mean, it blew my mind the first time I saw it. I'd best describe, hey, you to someone who's never seen it. They describe it. Big. It's maybe the size of a small house or a hut.
我召集了几个高中朋友，跟他们聊了聊，嘿，尤恩。感觉它似乎并没有像在我心中那样深深扎根在他们的脑海里。那是，我是说，我第一次看到它的时候，我的脑海简直被震撼了。我最好把海尤恩描述给一个从未见过它的人听。他们描述它。很大。它可能有一个小房子或小屋那么大。
And it looked like a high-air balloon. Like a jellyfish. A mushroom? A mushroomy sort of. A flowblig. Like a telescope observatory. Like a spaceship. A rocket ship. I mean, when you first look at it, you kind of think it's going to take off
它看起来像一个高空热气球。像一只水母。蘑菇？一种蘑菇状的东西。一个飞行物。像一个天文台。像一艘宇宙飞船。一艘火箭飞船。我的意思是，当你第一次看到它时，你会觉得它要起飞了
or something. It looks very alien and foreign, sitting in the middle of that big field. The place definitely has a stone-hedge feel to it. There were a number of myths about why he even was there, that it was built to commemorate the owner's dead daughter, that it was built along ley lines, that it was created for a wedding ceremony, that it was created for a wedding ceremony. That it was designed for paganistic rituals or for stargazing.
或者别的什么。它看起来非常异类和陌生，坐落在那片大片田野的正中央。这个地方绝对有一种巨石阵的感觉。关于海尤恩为什么会存在，有许多神话传说，有人说它是为了纪念主人死去的女儿而建造的，有人说它是沿着地脉建造的，有人说它是为婚礼仪式而创建的，有人说它是为婚礼仪式而创建的。有人说它是为异教仪式或观星而设计的。
The place was such an enigma. There's no way you could have known it was out there if someone didn't take you to it. The first person who founded has been lost to history, but by the time I was taken there, it was an oral tradition handed down from one group of teens to the next. Part of its power was that in being secret,
这个地方真是一个谜。如果没有人带你去看，你根本不可能知道外面有这个地方。最初发现它的人已经淹没在历史中，但当我被带到那里时，它已经成了一个口口相传的传统，从一代青少年传给下一代。它的力量部分在于，由于它是秘密的，
it created a community. It bound people together, appealing for an angry 15-year-old. It was a secret, sneaky, teenagers only, like, kids versus adults, secret time. Hey, you was mysterious, beautiful, and peaceful, and it just kind of reassured you about all of your inner turmoil, your deeper questions, I guess.
它创造了一个社区。它将人们联系在一起，吸引着一个愤怒的15岁少年。这是一个秘密的、偷偷摸摸的、只属于青少年的，比如孩子对抗成人的秘密时光。海尤恩是神秘的、美丽的、平静的，它在某种程度上让你内心所有的骚动、你更深层次的疑问都得到了某种安慰，我想。
It's almost like it was designed to inspire teenagers in the local area to come out there and hang out and drink beer and smoke pot and, you know, kind of capture their imagination. I probably went out there once every couple of months for the next four or five years. We'd go out there and drink, do drugs, sometimes just talk. And of course, it was always thrilling to bring new people out there, to indoctrinate them into our secret club.
它几乎就像是为了激励当地的青少年来到那里闲逛、喝啤酒、抽大麻而设计的，你知道的，某种程度上捕捉他们的想象力。在接下来的四五年里，我大概每隔几个月就会去那里一次。我们会去那里喝酒、吸毒，有时只是聊天。当然，带新人去那里，让他们加入我们的秘密俱乐部，总是让人兴奋不已。
Plenty of romantic relationships started out there. The first time I made out was someone who would become my girlfriend, happened while we were sitting on Hayun during a rain storm. It was otherworldly and magical. It felt out of time, and it felt like it was hours. Going to visit Hayune was the perfect mixture of danger and secrecy and awe to capture 15-year-old Alex's imagination for the next decade and a half. Even after I moved away in 2001, I was fixated on trying to find out why it was there. So in 2009, I wrote a letter to the White Farmhouse we always snuck past on our way to Hey-Yoon, asking them if they were the owners.
许多浪漫的恋情都是从那里开始的。我第一次亲热的对象后来成了我的女朋友，那是在一场暴风雨中，我们坐在海尤恩上发生的。那是超脱世俗的、神奇的。它感觉超越了时间，感觉像是过了几个小时。去参观海尤恩是将危险、神秘和敬畏完美融合的经历，它抓住了15岁亚历克斯在随后十五年里的想象力。即使我在2001年搬走后，我仍然痴迷于试图找出它为什么会存在。所以在2009年，我给那座我们去海尤恩时总是偷偷溜过去的白色农舍写了一封信，询问他们是否是业主。
Alex got a letter back. They didn't own Hey-Yoon. Their neighbors did. Rita and Peter Hayden. That's when I realized that what we'd been calling the Hay-Yoon pavilion for years was actually the Hayden pavilion. That Gaelic font made the D look kind of like a second O. And we'd only ever seen it in the middle of the night. If the names Rita and Peter Hayden sound familiar, it's probably because they're non-profit. The Mosaic Foundation has been underwriting public radio for decades. And by the Mosaic Foundation of Rita and Peter Hayden, based in an armor, honoring the
亚历克斯收到了一封回信。他们不拥有海尤恩。他们的邻居拥有。丽塔和彼得·海登。就在那时我意识到，我们多年来一直叫海尤恩亭的东西，其实是海登亭。那个盖尔语字体让字母D看起来有点像第二个O。而且我们一直都只在半夜看到过它。如果丽塔和彼得·海登这两个名字听起来很熟悉，那可能是因为他们是一个非营利组织。马赛克基金会几十年来一直在资助公共广播。而由位于安娜堡的丽塔和彼得·海登的马赛克基金会赞助，致敬
literary arts and the universe of great ideas, be well, do good work, and keep in touch. I sent the Hayden's a letter, apologizing for my youthful indiscretions and asking them if I could interview them about Hayun. Peter Hayden wrote back, quote, so you're one of the little s**t to invade our privacy by visiting our pavilion when you were told at many places along the way not to be there. End quote. This was in 2009 before I was a public radio producer. I was just a guy in New York who fixed computers, and a guy who used to trespass on the Hayden's property.
文学艺术和伟大思想的宇宙，祝你一切顺利，干得好，保持联系。我给海登夫妇写了一封信，为我年轻时的轻率行为道歉，并询问我是否可以采访他们关于海尤恩的事。彼得·海登回信写道，引述：“所以你就是那些小混混之一，当你在沿途许多地方被告知不应该去那里时，还是去我们的亭子参观，侵犯了我们的隐私。”引述结束。这是在2009年，在我成为公共广播制作人之前。我只是纽约一个修电脑的家伙，也是一个曾经擅闯海登夫妇财产的家伙。
The rest of his letter was friendly, but he wasn't too keen on talking to me. But I couldn't let it go that I communicated with the creator of Hey Yoon, and that the mystery could be solved. It drove me bonkers. So in 2012, after working in public radio for a couple of years, now I had a better excuse to try to talk to Hayden. And I decided to try again.
他信中的其余部分很友好，但他并不太热衷于跟我讲话。但我无法放下我与海尤恩的创造者进行过交流这件事，而且这个谜团可以被解开。这让我发疯。所以在2012年，在公共广播电台工作了几年之后，我现在有了更好的借口试图和海登对话。我决定再试一次。
Peter Hayden can be a hard man to reach. He doesn't use email. He doesn't always answer the phone. And he was reluctant to give an interview for fear of attracting even more people to Hayoon. But after a couple phone calls and a few facts messages, he agreed to meet me for an interview about Heyun at Heyun. It was like meeting the wizard of Oz.
彼得·海登可能是一个很难联系到的人。他不用电子邮件。他并不总是接电话。而且他不愿意接受采访，生怕会吸引更多的人来到海尤恩。但在打了几个电话和发了几条传真后，他同意在海尤恩与我见面，并就海尤恩接受我的采访。这就像是见到了绿野仙踪里的巫师。
What are you Alex? Yes I am. How do you do? Hi, nice to meet you. Nice to meet you. Let's go back up there. OK, which fence do you want to go to? We're going to the first gate just south of that white residence. All right
你是亚历克斯吗？是的，我是。你好吗？嗨，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。我们上去吧。好的，你想去哪个栅栏？我们要去那栋白色住宅正南方的第一个大门。好的。
This will be something new for you coming in legally. Yeah, and during the day The journey hasn't yeah, certainly has Alex nice to meet you nice to meet you Alex What a journey hasn't it? Yeah, certainly has. How you doing? I'm Peter. Alex, nice to meet you. Nice to meet you, Alex. Thank you so much for agreeing to do this. Yeah, I'm a mixed feelings of energy to imagine. Yeah, I bet.
合法地进来对你来说将是新鲜事。是的，而且是在白天。这段旅程确实，确实是——亚历克斯，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你，亚历克斯。真是一段旅程，不是吗？是的，确实是。你好吗？我是彼得。亚历克斯，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你，亚历克斯。非常感谢你同意这样做。是的，我的心情真是五味杂陈。是的，我敢肯定。
In my effort to try and respect the Hayden's privacy, I offered to refer to the pavilion only as Hayun and not use his name. But he told me from the beginning that he wasn't interested in anonymity. He was interested in privacy. I don't think that I want this to be anonymous. I want it to be with my name attached to it. But that doesn't mean to say that we have to violate our privacy. We don't have to tell where it is. We don't have to say whatever. I mean, if you said
为了努力尊重海登夫妇的隐私，我主动提出只把这座亭子称为海尤恩，而不使用他的名字。但他从一开始就告诉我，他对匿名不感兴趣。他感兴趣的是隐私。我认为我不想让这个匿名。我希望它能署上我的名字。但这并不意味着我们必须侵犯我们的隐私。我们不必说它在哪里。我们不必说别的什么。我的意思是，如果你说
Ann Arbor, that's good enough. Most people would not know. I was actually going to be even less specific. I was going to say southeastern Michigan to give people less of a So I know my name from our credit in PR in the mosaic foundation of Rita and Peter Hayden based in an arbor honoring the passion of NPR journalist all around the world whose stories take us there every day Because we always say based in an arbor. That's what it says. Right always Peter Hayden told me that Hayun was designed by a friend of his, an artist and designer named Joseph Kinnebroon. Kinnebroon is wife for visiting the Hayden's one night in 1978 when a massive blizzard came through and snowed the men. We were trapped in our house down at the bottom of the hill
安娜堡，那就足够好了。大多数人不会知道。我其实打算做得更模糊一点。我打算说密歇根州东南部，这样人们就不会……所以我知道我的名字来自我们在NPR的鸣谢，由位于安娜堡的丽塔和彼得·海登的马赛克基金会赞助，向世界各地NPR记者的激情致敬，他们的故事每天把我们带到那里，因为我们总是说位于安娜堡。就是这么说的。对的，总是这样。彼得·海登告诉我，海尤恩是由他的一个朋友、一位名叫约瑟夫·金布鲁的艺术家兼设计师设计的。1978年的一天晚上，金布鲁的妻子正在拜访海登夫妇，当时正赶上一场特大暴风雪，把他们大雪封山了。我们被困在山脚下的房子里
for five days, just the four of us. But we got to know each other quite well during that period. I think Joe is nuts and I like being around him. I find him, you know, a couple of them, the kind of person I'm not. The Haydons and the Kinebres got to be close. That spring, the Kinebres came back for a visit. And we went to a downtown restaurant. We got absolutely, it's sottingly drunk.
呆了五天，只有我们四个人。但在这期间我们相当深入地了解了彼此。我觉得乔是个疯子，而我喜欢和他在一起。我发现他，你知道的，和我是某种不同类型的人。海登夫妇和金布鲁夫妇变得很亲密。那年春天，金布鲁夫妇回来拜访。我们去了市中心的一家餐厅。我们喝得酩酊大醉。
We had planned, he'd said, I'm gonna build you up with me and I said, okay, we'll do this. And by dusk, we decided we'd come out here and look at this field and the position where the pavilion was going to be. I had nothing, I didn't have a flashlight, I didn't have anything. Our wives are parked right here, we were parked and they watched these two stumbling drunks walking across the field and Joe said, I can't see you. And I said, well, what are we going to do? And he said, well, he said in order for me to see you, I've got to have a light. And I
我们曾计划，他说，我要为你建一个——和我一起，我说，好吧，我们会这么做的。到了黄昏，我们决定来到这里，看看这片田野以及亭子将要建造的位置。我什么也没有，我没有带手电筒，我什么也没有。我们的妻子就停在这里，我们把车停好，她们看着这两个踉踉跄跄的醉汉走过田野，乔说，我看不见你。我说，好吧，我们该怎么办？他说，嗯，他说为了让我能看见你，我必须得有个光。而我
said, what's that going to be? And he be he said well here's a piece of the New York Times let's you do a flare so we'd let this stand and we could have set the whole field of light we didn't and so that was exactly the spot where I was standing with this burning newspaper it was funny stuff to watch us working that night. And that's how Peter Hayden and Joe Kinnebrook drunk and running around with a burning newspaper decided to build Hayun. Joe said that if Peter paid for the parts in labor, he'd do the design for free.
他说，那会是什么？然后他，他说，好吧，这里有一块《纽约时报》的报纸，我们用它来做个信号火炬吧，所以我们就让这个立着，我们本可以把整片光场都点亮的，但我们没有，所以那正是我拿着燃烧的报纸站着的地方，看我们那天晚上工作挺逗的。这就是彼得·海登和乔·金布鲁克在喝醉酒后，拿着燃烧的报纸到处跑时，决定建造海云的经过。乔说，如果彼得支付零件和人工费，他愿意免费设计。
I found it kind of oddly reassuring that the creation of Hayun came out of the same sort of drunk and antics my friends and I would get into almost two decades later at the same spot, that you could trace its origin story back to a sleepover party. But on the other hand, Peter couldn't give me any particular reason for its existence. It's just there because it is, because it's beautiful, because it's art. No, it was a professive English at the University of Michigan for 24 or 5 years, I was a professor of English at the University of Michigan for 24 or 5 years starting in the 1960s. I have a kind of an aesthetic view of what art is. It teaches you steps by which wisdom is gained. In that sense, art is useless.
我发现，海云的诞生源于我和朋友们在大约二十年后在同一个地方会陷入的那种醉酒后的滑稽举动，这种巧合让人感到一种奇异的宽慰，你可以把它的起源追溯到一个留宿派对。但另一方面，彼得无法给我任何关于它存在的具体理由。它就在那里，因为它是，因为它美丽，因为它艺术。不，我在密歇根大学当了24或5年的英语教授，从20世纪60年代开始，我在密歇根大学当了24或5年的英语教授。我对艺术是什么有一种美学观点。它教导你获得智慧的阶梯。从这个意义上说，艺术是无用的。
It doesn't have any practical impact. And so for me, this pavilion was always sort of that. It was something that was a place for contemplation, a place for pleasure, for enjoyment, for communityality with people that I chose to be here. Peter's relationship with Hayun feels like an echo of the possessiveness, the secretiveness, the ownership that me and my friends all feel for it. The only difference is that Peter actually owns it. Like us, he feels protective of it. Unlike us, he's actually responsible for it.
它没有任何实际的影响。所以对我来说，这个亭子一直就是那种东西。它是一个供人沉思的地方，一个供人快乐、享受、与我选择来到这里的人进行社群交流的地方。彼得与海云的关系感觉就像是我和朋友们对它所感受到的独占欲、神秘感、所有权的一种回响。唯一的区别是彼得 realmente 拥有它。和我们一样，他觉得有责任保护它。与我们不同的是，他 realmente 要为它负责。
Over the years, he's had to clean up the messes left by drunk teens and even some damage left by vandals. Unlike you, Alex, you were some s**t heads that came out here and actually did some damage left by vandals. Unlike you, Alex, there were some sh** heads that came out here and actually did some damage. And we had to repair that. They actually cut the covering. We know that there were parties out here. We had candles and things like that. Sometimes it looked like there maybe had been sort of religious things going on here.
多年来，他不得不清理喝醉的青少年留下的烂摊子，甚至还有破坏者留下的损坏。不像你，亚历克斯，你们是一些来这里并真正造成破坏的混蛋。不像你，亚历克斯，这里有一些来这里并真正造成破坏的混蛋。我们不得不修理这些。他们真的割破了顶棚。我们知道这里曾有过聚会。我们点过蜡烛之类的东西。有时看起来这里可能发生过某种宗教活动。
There may have been poetry readings. And it was, you know, I think a hefty amount of sex. I don't think there were orgies out here, but I think that couples would come out here and find it very compelling to be part of nature out here and be one with the nature, especially on full moons and stuff, that was always a very seem to be an attractive time for people to be out here. I'm curious, you know, while I was talking to my friends about the signage that's out
可能还有诗歌朗诵。你知道的，我认为还有相当多的性行为。我不认为这里有过狂欢，但我认为情侣们会来到这里，发现在大自然中成为一体是非常吸引人的，尤其是在满月之夜之类的时刻，对人们来说，这似乎一直是一个很有吸引力的来到这里的时间。我很好奇，你知道的，当我跟我的朋友们谈论外面的标识时
front and the first sign, the sign that says, you know, sort of respect this and leave this in peace. Congratulations. This is your reward for finding this. And you said quite that out. It's taking, congratulations. I didn't say that. It didn't work in me that much.
正面那个标牌，那个写着，你知道的，某种尊重这一点并让这里保持平静的标牌。恭喜。这就是你找到这个地方的奖励。而你却把那话说得……这需要……恭喜。我可没那么说。它在我身上没起那么大作用。
I don't think. But anyway, please continue. Well, the reason I say that is because one of my friends said to me, I kind of believe that they wanted us to go out there. They wanted us to find it and that's why there are so many signs daring us to visit it. No, that's absolutely fabricated. That's wishful thinking on your part. Nothing like that of the sort we wanted. If I choose to utilize it, that's my business.
我想没有。不过总之，请继续。好吧，我这么说的原因是我的朋友对我说，我有点相信他们是故意让我们去那里的。他们希望我们找到它，这就是为什么有那么多标牌在挑衅我们去参观。不，这完全是捏造的。那是你一厢情愿的想法。根本没有那种事，我们才不想呢。如果我选择使用它，那是我的事。
That's my religious experience. It's not a common temple for everyone to utilize. It's funny you should temple for everyone to utilize. It's funny you should put it that way because that's exactly how my friends and I all felt about it then. And still do now, even though we ourselves were trespassers. One of my friends who I talked to for this story, Jason van Maider, put it this way. There were like certain kids who would, I would talk to when they'd say like, oh yeah, that pavilion out there, like I took a six pack out there, we got wasted out there the other night or whatever.
那是我的宗教体验。它不是供所有人使用的公共寺庙。你这么说真搞笑，因为这正是当年我和朋友们对它的看法。现在依然如此，尽管我们自己也是闯入者。我为这个故事采访过的一位朋友，杰森·范·迈德，是这样说的：有一些孩子，我会和他们交谈，他们会说，哦，对，外面那个亭子，我上次带了一箱啤酒去那儿，我们在那儿喝醉了什么的。
And I'd feel a little bit hurt by that. Like, why are you just going out there to drink? You know, you're just talking to me about your 30 pack of people are out at the pavilion, like, sacrilegious, you know? That's like my church. It's like you're sacrilegging my church. When we found trash at Hayoon, leftover from other people, my friends and I would clean it up,
我对此会感到有点受伤。就像，你为什么只是去那里喝酒？你知道的，你只是在跟我谈论你那箱30瓶的啤酒，人们在亭子里，这太亵渎神明了，你知道吗？就像那是我的教堂。就像你在亵渎我的教堂一样。当我们在海云发现别人留下来的垃圾时，我和我的朋友们会把它清理干净，
or at least try to minimize our impact on the place. But for Peter, that doesn't matter. We were all just a bunch of interlopers. Did you go to Pioneer High School? I actually went to all three. I went to Pioneer Community and here on in the course of my troubled high school career. Okay, what do you say? Presumably along the way there, at least you learned the English language. You were able to read things, especially something that's subtle like that, like that. But I would challenge you to say that was an invitation. It was not an invitation.
或者至少尽量减少我们对这个地方的影响。但对彼得来说，这并不重要。我们都只是一群不速之客。你读过先锋高中吗？其实我三所都读过。在我充满波折的高中生涯中，我读过先锋高中、社区高中和休伦高中。好吧，那你怎么说？大概在那一路上，至少你学会了英语。你能够阅读东西，尤其是像那样微妙的东西，比如那个标牌。但我敢说那是一个邀请。那不是一个邀请。
It was really meant to say, look, here's the fact, you're here. You've come to this place. I don't want you to do any damage and I don't want to piss you off. So here's what I'm telling you. You know, leave. Admire its beauty, but leave. Don't stay here, leave.
它其实是想说，看，事实是这样的，你在这里。你来到了这个地方。我不想让你搞破坏，我也不想惹恼你。所以这就是我要告诉你的。你知道，离开。欣赏它的美，但离开。不要留在这里，离开。
And I think that was the message that I wanted to be. I didn't want them to, I didn't, because it's like, you know, spending 20 minutes in your sock drawer as opposed to five minutes for two minutes in your sock drawer. It's just, in some way it became kind of polluted to me in some ways when people, people that I didn't know didn't invite, had nothing to, had no knowledge of, and whose values and whose sense of aesthetics were not the same as mine, I felt that, you know, it's a personal violation.
我想那正是我想要传达的信息。我不想让他们，我不想，因为这就像是，你知道的，花20分钟在你的抽袜子的抽屉里，而不是花五分钟或两分钟在抽袜子的抽屉里。在某种程度上，当一些我不认识的、没有邀请的、一无所知的、其价值观和审美品味与我不同的人来到这里时，这个地方对我来说在某种程度上变得有点被污染了，我觉得，你知道的，这是一种个人的侵犯。
Talking with Peter, I can see how much he values privacy and having control over the stuff he owns. He hired a former cop to drive a decommissioned police car around his property. It's got lights and sirens and a logo that says RPH security as in Rita and Peter Hayden. He says it's mostly to keep out hunters. What I say is we don't allow hunters, we allow a hunter who wants this property. And he's entitled to take one buck a year as many doses he wants. And when he did catch kids that were out there to sneak into Hey-Yoon,
与彼得交谈后，我能看出他有多么重视隐私以及对自己所拥有东西的控制权。他雇了一个前警察开着一辆退役的警车在他的土地上巡逻。车上有灯光、警笛和一个写着“RPH保安”的标志，也就是丽塔和彼得·海登（Rita and Peter Hayden）的名字缩写。他说这主要是为了把猎人挡在外面。我所说的是我们不允许猎人，我们允许一个想要这块土地的猎人。他有权每年带走一只雄鹿和任意数量的母鹿。当他真的抓到潜入海云的小孩时，
he'd make them give their names and addresses and make them write letters of apology. He still has a lot of those letters. Yet for all of Peter's possessiveness of Hey-Yoon, he doesn't actually do a lot with it. You know, the place itself is not meant to be used for me anyway. In other words, it's perfectly good being by itself, not having any occupants. Peter hosts private wine tastings once or twice a year in Hey-Eun, and maybe Hollander
他会让他们说出姓名和地址，并让他们写道歉信。他现在还保留着许多这样的信。然而，尽管彼得对海云有着强烈的占有欲，但他其实并没有用它做太多事情。你知道的，这个地方本身并不是用来使用的，对我和我来说都不是。换句话说，它保持原样、没有任何占用者，就已经非常好了。彼得每年在海云举办一两次私人品酒会，也许偶尔会从他的房子散步
over to it from his house from time to time, but that's pretty much it. And it doesn't really matter. Peter's the actual owner of Hey-Eun, and he can but that's pretty much it. And it doesn't really matter. Peter's the actual owner of Heyun, and he can do anything he wants with it. He can use it, he can not use it. He even talked to me about how he's thought of tearing it down. And he can, it's his progative.
过来看看，但差不多也就这样了。这其实也无所谓。彼得是海云真正的所有者，他可以——但差不多也就这样了。彼得是海云真正的所有者，他可以对它做任何他想做的事。他可以使用它，也可以不使用它。他甚至跟我谈过他曾考虑过把它拆掉。他完全可以这么做，这是他的特权。
The way Heyun gets used, or doesn't get used, is under total control of the Haytons. But when you think about design intent, what Heyun was actually designed to do, there's one other person for whom it might be fair game to weigh in. This guy. I'm so happy, in spite of Peter's unhappiness about interlovers, that young people came in to sneak a peek. This of course is Joseph Kinabru, the designer of Hey Yoon.
海云被使用的方式，或者不被使用的方式，完全在海淀一家的控制之下。但是，当你考虑设计意图——海云被设计出来到底是为了做什么——还有另一个人，对他来说参与讨论可能是公平的。这个人。我非常高兴，尽管彼得对不速之客很不高兴，但年轻人还是会来这里偷看一眼。这个人当然就是乔·金布鲁克，海云的设计者。
The guy who got drunk and set newspapers on fire with Peter Hayden back in the day. He left Michigan decades ago and never had any idea that Hey Yoon had become such an underground attraction. His take is somewhat different than Peter Hayden's. I'm delighted, I'm absolutely delighted. How could I not feel something really good about what you did even though you weren't supposed to? You were all quite naughty, but that's quite alright. It's one of those things that life should include.
当年那个和彼得·海登一起喝醉酒并点燃报纸的家伙。他几十年离开密歇根，根本不知道海云已经成了一个地下热门景点。他的看法与彼得·海登有些不同。我很高兴，我绝对高兴。对于你们做过的事，尽管你们本不应该这么做，我怎么能不感到非常高兴呢？你们都很淘气，但这没关系。这是生活应该包含的事情之一。
Granted, Joseph Kinnebrew, unlike Peter Hayden, doesn't have to deal with interlopers, coming onto his property doing God knows what under the cloak of darkness. But Kinnebrew says that it's bigger than a question of property. It's the impact that the pavilion has on the landscape, on the psyche of the people who come into contact with it, through means legitimate or not. For Kenobru, Hayun is out in the world. Contidine tomato paste, you have this wonderful thing that you used to say, you know, once they're peeled or packed, of course, to the tomatoes.
当然，约瑟夫·金布鲁克不像彼得·海登那样，需要应付那些闯入他的土地、在夜色的掩护下不知在干什么的闯入者。但金布鲁克说，这比财产问题更宏大。这是亭子对风景的影响，对那些接触到它的人的心灵的影响，无论这种接触是否合法。对金布鲁克来说，海云属于这个世界。就像番茄酱罐头，你过去常说一句妙语，你知道的，西红柿一旦被去皮或装罐，当然了。
And I feel to a certain degree, the same thing about artwork. You know, once it's done, it's done. I'm gone, I'm out of the picture. It doesn't even belong to me anymore. I'm not even sure that thing belongs to the head. You see, possessing it has nothing to do with it. Absolutely nothing.
在某种程度上，我对艺术品也有同样的看法。你知道的，一旦它完成了，就完成了。我走了，我出局了。它甚至不再属于我了。我甚至不确定那东西属于海淀。你看，拥有它与它毫无关系。绝对毫无关系。
I remember as a youngster sneaking off to look at something called Peabody's tomb, which is the Somazaliam and a forbidden monastery that we all visited on occasion about the same age you were. She was west of Chicago where I grew up. And allegedly Peabody was in this glass coffin where these candles were lit every night. We were to sneak out there as soon. Here you are, you're 33 years old, forgot sick.
我记得年轻时曾偷偷溜去看一个叫皮博迪之墓的地方，那是一个陵墓和一个禁忌的修道院，我们在差不多你这个年纪时偶尔会去参观。它位于我长大的芝加哥以西。据说皮博迪就躺在这个玻璃棺材里，周围每晚都点着蜡烛。我们一……你就这样，你33岁了，真让人恶心。
You're still holding on to it. What a wonderful thing. Even though I'm sure it pisses Peter Hayden off to say this, I can't help but feel like a part of Hayoon belongs to me. I think that other people I know have a similar feeling. There were a couple of people who refused to talk to me for this story, because to them, to share Hayoon with the world is to ruin Hayoon.
你还抓着它不放。多美妙的事啊。尽管我确信彼得·海登听到这话会气急败坏，但我还是忍不住觉得海云的一部分属于我。我想我认识的其他其他人也有类似的感觉。有几个人拒绝就这个故事接受我的采访，因为对他们来说，与世界分享海云就是毁了海云。
We found a photographer who had taken some pictures of Hayoon, but when we asked him if we could post them to our website, he replied with an enthatic, no, he did not want the secret getting out on his watch. And I have to admit, I understand where they're coming from. But on the other side of the coin, when I put out a call to friends on Facebook to see who would talk to me about Hey-Un, some wrote, what's Hey-Un? And that gave me the same sense of exclusivity, of belonging that I had when I was a teenager. And now, over the course of producing this story, I've actually gained a kind of buy-in from the grand arbiter of Hey-Yoon himself.
我们找到了一位给海云拍过照片的摄影师，但当我们问他是否可以把照片发布到我们的网站上时，他斩钉截铁地回答说不，他不想在自己眼皮底下让这个秘密泄露出去。我必须承认，我理解他们的想法。但在硬币的另一面，当我在Facebook上向朋友们发出呼吁，看看谁愿意跟我聊聊海云时，有些人写道：“什么是海云？”这让我回想起当我还是个青少年时所感到的那种排他性、那种归属感。现在，在这个故事的制作过程中，我实际上得到了海云本身的超级仲裁者的某种认可。
I'm no longer just a little s**t to Peter Hayden. Alex, look, you're a different person than you were then. Secondly, as you know, I'm a radio guy. I like voices and I like the word pictures that people can weave on the radio. You came credentialed because I hear your voice, I hear your name, Alex, and this morning I heard your name on the media again. I was like, what do you, what's your associate producer? Yeah. Yeah, well, I'm proud of you for doing that. What?
在彼得·海登眼中，我不再只是个小混蛋了。亚历克斯，听着，你和以前是不同的人了。其次，如你所知，我是个广播人。我喜欢声音，我喜欢人们在广播中编织的文字画面。你带着资历来，因为我听到你的声音，我听到你的名字，亚历克斯，今天早上我又在媒体上听到了你的名字。我当时想，你是做什么的，你是副制片人？对。是的，好吧，我为你做这件事感到骄傲。什么？
What? What? What? What? What? I'm grateful that I ever got to see Hey-Un. That I live in a world where Hey-Un exists. But I'm also grateful that I live in a world where there are magnificent structures that
什么？什么？什么？什么？我很感激我曾经见过海云。我生活在一个海云存在的世界里。但我也很感激我生活在一个拥有宏伟建筑的世界里
are made without me in mind, with nobody in mind. And while I may have gotten a lot out of it and attempted to protect it by only gifting it to certain people, the Haydons are just trying to do the same thing. So even though this feels a little hypocritical, I have to say it. If you ever find yourself out in the middle of nowhere in southeastern Michigan, and you happen to come across some foreboding signs along the side of the road. As a favor to the Haydons, and to me and my friends, please, now, turn back and leave in peace.
这些建筑在建造时并没有把我放在心上，没有把任何人放在心上。虽然我可能从中收获了很多，并通过只把它当成礼物送给特定的人来试图保护它，但海登一家也只是在做同样的事情。所以，尽管这听起来有点虚伪，但我不得不说。如果你发现自己身处密歇根州东南部偏僻的荒郊野岭，恰巧在路边遇到一些不祥的标牌。作为对海登一家，以及对我还有我的朋友们的一个人情，请吧，现在，转身回去，平静地离开。
Leave. Don't stay here. Leave. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Alex Goldman and Sam Greenspan with me Roman Mars. The people Alex interviewed about breaking to Heyun with him when he was a kid were Rob Logan, Kara Kavarren, Ben Tidswell, Ian Ryan, Fred Thomas, Jason Van Maider, and Alex Bird. Hopefully the statute of limitations on trespassing is up by now.
离开。不要留在这里。离开。《99%隐形》本周由亚历克斯·戈德曼（Alex Goldman）和萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）与我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）共同制作。亚历克斯采访的那些小时候曾和他一起私闯海云的人有：罗布·洛根（Rob Logan）、卡拉·卡瓦伦（Kara Kavarren）、本·蒂德斯韦尔（Ben Tidswell）、伊恩·瑞安（Ian Ryan）、弗雷德·托马斯（Fred Thomas）、杰森·范·迈德（Jason Van Maider）和亚历克斯·伯德（Alex Bird）。希望非法入侵的诉讼时效现在已经过了。
Special thanks to our cast of radio players, including Cameron Locke, Mujzaity, Ashley and Crit Bomb, and Pat Masidi Miller. They did not break into Hey You and they faked it all in my backyard. So please don't write us and ask us how to find Hey You. We do not know. Alex did not tell us.
特别感谢我们的广播演员阵容，包括卡梅伦·洛克（Cameron Locke）、穆扎伊蒂（Mujzaity）、阿什利和克里特·邦姆（Crit Bomb），以及帕特·马西迪·米勒（Pat Masidi Miller）。他们没有私闯海云，他们全是在我后院假装的。所以请不要写信给我们，问我们如何找到海云。我们不知道。亚历克斯没有告诉我们。
I can't want you to say like, I've been about a flashlight. Okay. And then I would say, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, we can't be even flashlight. So let's go. Don't laugh because you're in a mess up the recording. Hey, no flashlights, no flashlights.
我不能让你说，比如，我带了手电筒。好吧。然后我会说，不，不，不，不，不，我们不能带手电筒。所以我们走吧。别笑，因为你会搞砸录音的。嘿，没有手电筒，没有手电筒。
No flashlights. As in character, I was acting being an actor. No, nah, nah, no flashlights. Should I start over? I should really have to be. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars. But as I said, we couldn't post photos of Hayun, so we had the incredibly talented graphic artist Emil Homewood of the caravan make us some really great illustrations to go with this episode.
没有手电筒。我是入戏了，我是在当演员。不，不，不，没有手电筒。我要重新开始吗？我真的必须……不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，旧金山的KALW电台和旧金山美国建筑师学会。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞，我在推特上是@romanmars。但正如我所说，我们无法发布海云的照片，所以我们请了来自大篷车的才华横溢的平面艺术家埃米尔·霍姆伍德（Emil Homewood）为我们制作了一些非常棒的插图来配合这一集。
So the story continues at 99personinvisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，故事在 99percentinvisible.org 上继续。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。